personnel d'activité procès selim
défendre les individus dont les yeux
eric ciotti merci monsieur le président
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
premier ministre depuis plus d'un mois
notre pays est le théâtre de
manifestations de plus en plus violente
chaque jour ou plutôt chaque nuit
commerce chaque âge et véhicules
incendiés policiers caillassés offre le
triste spectacle de l'état de droit qui
recule devant la loi des casseurs
plus de 400 policiers ont été blessés
depuis le début de ces manifestations de
violence dont certains grièvement
en cet instant je voudrais rendre
l'hommage qu'il mérite aux policiers
pour leur courage face à ces
manifestations
je voudrais aussi je voudrais aussi
dénoncé ceux qui incitent à la haine et
à la violence et notamment la cgt au
travers des affiches honteuse qui
portent atteinte à l'intégrité des
policiers
monsieur le premier ministre vous
disposez des outils juridiques pour
faire cesser cette situation nous sommes
un état d'urgence
le parlement l'a décidé les français ne
comprennent pas la complaisance dont
vous faites preuve face à ces mouvements
de violence
aujourd'hui les mots ne suffisent plus
il faut agir
vous avez le devoir de protéger ce qui
nous protège
vous avez le devoir de faire en sorte
que la place de la république ne soit
pas abandonnée à nuit debout qui est un
mouvement d'extrême gauche qui portent
atteinte à nos valeurs essentielles
alors monsieur le premier ministre mais
question seront simples quand allez-vous
évacué la place de la république
quand allez-vous conformément à l'état
d'urgence interdire les manifestations
violentes
quand allez-vous porter plainte contre
les affiches de la cgt quand allez-vous
dissoudre les mouvements
d'extrême-gauche
rose et vient de dieu bernard cazeneuve
ministre de l'intérieur monsieur le
député ciotti je voudrais profiter de
votre question pour apporter des
réponses précises notamment sur trois
aspects des événements qui se sont
produits au cours des dernières semaines
premièrement monsieur ciotti vous parlez
de complaisance depuis maintenant deux
mois que ces manifestations ont commencé
grâce à l'action des forces de l'ordre
que je veux à mon tour saluer et parce
que des instructions leur ont été
données extrêmement précise de ma part
par télégramme que j'ai d'ailleurs
publié et que je transmettrai à la
commission des lois de l'assemblée
nationale et du sénat pour que vous
puissiez en prendre connaissance
mille interpellations ont eu lieu 1000
et jeudi dernier plus de 200 et ces
interpellations monsieur ciotti parce
qu'il ya une excellente relation entre
les préfets des procureurs ont fait
l'objet de mises en examen ont fait
l'objet de mises sous écrou ont fait
l'objet de comparution immédiate
donc lorsque vous parlez de complaisance
c'est sans doute parce que vous êtes mal
informé parce que je ne peux pas
imaginer une minute que sur la base des
éléments que je viens de vous indiquer
vous envoyer dans un climat d'extrême
tension par démagogie dans l'opinion
publique
des petits bobos barça vous ressemble
tellement peu les petits bobards
monsieur ciotti et les outrances que je
ne peux pas imaginer une minute que ce
soit ce type de considérations qui
préside à votre question
donc voilà très clairement sur le
premier point la réponse nous sommes
intraitables avec l'état les casseurs
nous sommes d'une fermeté absolue
les interpellations en témoigne et les
forces de l'ordre s'expose pour assurer
ces interpellations
deuxièmement parce que je suis
république a vraiment pour ce qui me
concerne je souhaite que l'usagé de la
force soit proportionnée parce que la
république c'est la volonté du maintien
de l'ordre dans le respect rigoureux des
individus de ceux qui manifestent et des
libertés publiques
enfin troisièmement et je tiens à le
dire très clairement je ne suis pas
d'accord avec ceux qui manifestent rue
de la république
mais je ferai tout pour qu'il puisse le
faire c'est ce que nous incite à faire
mon chéri constitutionnel